it can be hard to fully come to terms
with what happens here
roof island the property of sierra mario
but it was time for prince charles to
listen
at the national archives in bridgetown
he was told of the atrocities carried
out by their colonial masters
the death and torture suffered by
thousands of enslaved africans brought
here to work
as barbados marked its first day
separated from the royal family
campaigner david denney didn't want the
prince to come he believes now is
finally the time to talk seriously about
reparations
there's no space for the royal family in
that celebration what the royal family
need to do is to
apologize
for slavery
the royal family need to
pay reparation
for slavery
the appalling atrocity of slavery which
forever stains our history
acknowledging the pain of the past he'd
been invited by prime minister mia
motley to attend the transition ceremony
it's now to her to take to the world
stage those calls for compensation
what's interesting when you speak to
people here is they'll make the point
that reparations isn't just about the uk
handing over cash they need investment
in things like roads and technology they
want young people to get scholarships
for universities and it's those kind of
things that they say will make a real
difference as they continue to wrestle
with issues like unemployment the
climate crisis and of course covert 19.
similar challenges faced by other
caribbean islands some of their leaders
joining the prince and the new president
for a toast whether other realms will
follow and remove the queen is now the
big question she currently serves as
head of state for 15 nations
jamaica australia and canada have all
discussed dropping the monarchy in
recent years
in jamaica mike henry is an mp leading
the demand for reparations and a split
from the royals we should have been a
republican from the time of independence
that is when we should have demanded a
settlement but at that point we didn't
know who owned the slaves at that point
we were told we could manage our own
affairs and therefore there were reasons
why you wouldn't pay us unsettled for us
one element of soft influence that will
remain in barbados is the prince's trust
as the future head of the commonwealth
he knows he must move with the times in
his mother's reign so much has changed
and inevitably there is more to come
rihanna mills sky news in barbados